if you want to dip back into Dark Souls  3 before the last DLC pack drops you'll  be able to do so with new features I'm  Tony and this GameSpot news update is  preparing to die Dark Souls threes next  update sets it up for the Ring City  expansion and it fixes some PvP bugs and  balance issues but the real meat of the  patch is in its ps4 pro support which  increases the games overall framerate  community manager Koo Mundi said the  frame rate would vary so there's no  guarantee it'll hit a maximum of 60 FPS  but be sure to subscribe to be the first  to know about any other changes Dark  Souls threes 1.1 1 update goes live on  Friday March 24th just a few days before  the ring city drops on the 28th and if  you want to see the dlc in action right  now you can check out our first boss  fight against the demon prince  good luck ashen one  [Music]